let's bring in today's political panel
much to discuss grv strategy's founder
former Communications advisor to Iowa
Senator Chuck Grassley and Senior
advisor to the Senate Judiciary
Committee Garrett ventry and former
deputy press secretary for the
Democratic National Committee Jose
aristimuno gentlemen happy New Year
happy New Year Mike okay so let's start
out with uh Kevin McCarthy does he or
doesn't he get to 218 here's more from
California Congressman Daryl Isa let's
play it
you can't make a decision on somebody
with nobody and quite frankly there is
no alternative to Kevin he clearly is
our choice broadly and he's earned it
he's earned it over more than a decade
of incredible hard work in a leadership
Jose does Kevin McCarthy get it done
I think it will I think he will show
look I think he'll get a 218 volts in it
Mike but he does show that the
Republican leadership is somewhat
divided so um the question is I'm I
wouldn't be he's going to get elected
I'm not surprised by that but I think
can McCarthy actually lead the
Republican uh house uh to get things
done for the American people that's real
that's really the big question at last
check Arizona Republican Congressman
Andy Biggs is still holding out let's
hear from him
uh I don't think so I I do not think so
and here's why he's got a body of work
um you go back to 17 and 18. look at the
look at why we had Democrats voting for
The Republican budgets because the
Republicans didn't want those budgets
but the floor leader Mr McCarthy cut
those deals with the Democrats
Garrett is this new Republican majority
in the house at risk of stumbling out of
the gate with a fight over their next
leader well I think it's clear and
Congressman ice is right about this I
mean leader McCarthy has very strong
support within the conference he is the
Republican nominee based on the
conference vote uh if you look at two
his vote coming out of conference is
right on par with speaker Paul Ryan and
Nancy Pelosi who both became speaker he
crisscrossed the country shattered
fundraising records now look the
majority is a little more slim than a
lot of people forecasters pollsters and
operatives thought it would be but the
reality is here that Republicans are
going to unify around Kevin McCarthy
there cannot be chaos in the house floor
here we've got to get right to work for
the American people start doing
investigations start implementing the
commitment to America so I think he does
get there I think you got to remember
Kevin McCarthy has shown he's willing to
deal with conservatives Jim Jordan
opposed him in 2018 and now he's one of
his strongest allies a member of the
freedom caucus as is Marjorie Taylor
green so I think at the end of the day
Republic will come together he's willing
to make concessions smartly and he is
the only one right now who's a viable
candidate and I believe he will become
the next Speaker of the House for
Republicans one possible concession
would be the motion to vacate the chair
which means that some members of his own
ranks could basically decapitate the
speaker at any time and he's not going
to go there is he Garrett I mean that's
going to be a discussion that him and
his team are going to have to have with
members to see what the appetite is
there there's obviously more moderate
members that have some concerns about
that but at the end of the day I think
that leader McCarthy has shown that he
has been a powerful fundraiser and even
an ally of a lot of conservatives in the
house all right let's get to Jose's
wheelhouse the Democrats and the
Democrats are high on their new leader
Hakeem Jeffries after a long time of
Nancy Pelosi steny Hoyer and Company
being in charge Hakeem Jeffrey seen as a
rising star but he's untested in that
top job will there be some Growing Pains
Jose
well look I think he's been he's been
taught by the best he's worked with
Nancy Pelosi of Nancy Pelosi for a long
time he's being Congress for um over 10
years um he's young right I think he's a
little over 50 years old so I think
he'll do he'll do just fine he's been
he's been a leader within Democrats and
part of the democratic caucus for a
while now so I think he's the right
choice I'm optimistic uh and I look
forward to seeing what he will get done
for Democrats and the American people
okay let's talk about the Border crisis
gentlemen a hot issue as we start a
brand new year uh record numbers
crossing the border illegally
um to that border crisis a republican
congresswoman from Texas says Democrats
are spending on it but not on the right
priorities let's play it they just
passed the largest Omnibus in our in our
nation's history 1.7 trillion dollars
800 million of it went down to Customs
and Border Protection but not to protect
or to secure our borders but to do
things like pay for tents pay for
Barbers pay for transportation of these
folks through our country
what about that concern from
congresswoman Van Dyne so just so folks
know what title 42 is it's thrown around
a lot it was a covet era policy that was
implemented that essentially allowed
border patrol agents to expel migrants
who are flooding the Border obviously
Mike as you pointed out at record Paces
here and what you're seeing at the
border patrol it's being overrun in a
lot of ways and the Biden Administration
seems not really interested in doing
anything about it obviously the Supreme
Court stepped in here it sets up a
future battle but you have fentanyl
coming across the border you've had
multiple very dangerous terrorist
attempt to cross here and so it's
shocking to me that Democrats don't want
to fix with this now as the
congresswoman pointed out it's also very
interesting that they've sent in their
two trillion dollar omnimus billions of
dollars to secure the border and other
countries but not here that's obviously
a problem that House Republicans
identified and will work to fix and
we'll have a lot of Leverage going into
spending bills and a number of other
issues to be able to try and get a fix
here going forward Jose let's get you
into this conversation on the border
what do Democrats do in the new year
look immigration is a tough issue for
both Republicans and Democrats I agree
with Garrett that uh part of this is can
you know can Congress come together and
not just put money but put money in the
right places so border enhancement I
think it's important I think we got to
do something uh when it comes to that
then real long-time solution might for
this is comprehensive immigration
there's no way uh about it I think that
there was a bill that was put in place
in in December that said let's help the
dreamers right those young kids who came
to this country and no fault of their
own and let's put money uh behind the
Border this this year there's been
record apprehensions at the border so
it's not that the border patrol are not
doing their jobs they're doing their
jobs but they actually need more
resources so if Republicans and
Democrats can come together and get
immigration reform done for the American
people I think that would be a great uh
goal for 2023 can't they get it done
that's a big question that's a great
question Garrett is a guy who covered
the hill for more than a decade the
thoughts of comprehensive immigration
reform scared some folks uh divided
government government is an opportunity
to get some things done if there's the
willpower to do it do they get at least
partial immigration reform done in this
new divided government well I think
we've seen this before President Trump
obviously offered a deal on DACA with
house democrats for border wall funding
and that fell through there you know
we've seen this since really 2008 and
even previously to that where both
parties were there as a divided
government essentially and a lot of
stuff doesn't get done here so I
wouldn't be generally that optimistic
about something getting done on
immigration reform broadly but on
securing the Border I think both parties
should be able to come together provide
resources for border patrol agents who
are serving districts not even just in
Texas but all the way up in New York and
other places as well Garrett ventry Jose
arist Munoz gentlemen thanks so much
Happy New Year happy New Year good to be
with you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else